par cet amendement il s'agit d'instaurer
dans notre pays un prix minimum de
l'alcool la fiscalité a certes pour
effet de produire des recettes à l'état
mais elle a aussi un autre objectif et
en l'occurrence sur les substances comme
l'alcool ou le tabac c'est de essayer
d'en réduire l'impact sur la santé or
notre système
actuel cible trop mal les 8 % de
Français qui consomment 50 de l'alcool
c'est-à-dire qui ont une consommation
excessive qui atteint fortement leur
état de santé l'Écosse a mis en place en
2018 ce prix minimum de l'alcool alors
il ne génère pas de taxes supplémentaire
et d'ailleurs notre amendement nous
avons dû le gager ça montre bien qu'il
n'a pas un impact qui est d'accroître en
l'occurrence la pression
fiscale les effets de cette adoption
2018 ont été mesurés pour la première
fois en 2023 et ils montre une baisse
des décès li à l'alcool une baisse des
hospitalisations et cette baisse est
particulièrement ciblée sur les
consommateurs excessifs et il faut aussi
le noter sur les zones du pays qui sont
les plus défavorisées sur un plan social
et économique et donc il y a un grand
intérêt à instituer ce primimum de
l'alcool parce que il va permettre de
modifier les prélèvements en améliorant
l'efficacité en terme de santé publique
sans accroître globalement la pression
fiscale voilà pourquoi nous avons déposé
cet amendement avec les cosignataires
nous pensons que c'est un débat
indispensable il faut que notre pays
évolue en la matière parce que garder
figer la fiscalité année après année et
en être réduit à discuter d'exonération
de cotisation sociale FSS n'est pas
satisfaisant je vous remercie merci
l'amendement
1732ame gu oui je suis là monsieur le
Président donc c'est le même amendement
que l'amendement précédemment
effectivement il s'agit alors pas tout à
fait d'une taxe mais de l'instauration
d'un prix minimum d'alcool qui est un un
sujet plutôt comportemental qui cible
effectivement la consommation des
consommateurs d'alcool de manière
excessive est très excessive on sait
bien que l'alcool est un fléo de santé
publique c'est 42000 morts par an alors
je dis pas l'alcool je vais redire la
consommation excessive et très excessive
d'alcool est un fléo en matière de santé
publique avec 42000 morts par an de
décès direct 3 milliards quand même pour
le coût des finances publiques on est
sur un PLF et si on y ajoute le coût
social c'est 102 milliards d'euros par
an le coût de la consommation excessive
d'alcool donc on s'est inspiré en fait
d'un d'un un amendement qui a été
institué en Écosse en 2018 qui a prouvé
en fait l'efficacité de cet amendement
puisqueen fait il a réduit la
consommation d'alcool il a réduit le
coût des finances enfin en tout cas le
coût induit de l'alcool pour les
finances publiques et il a également
réduit le nombre de décès donc l'idée
c'est effectivement de de de tenter de
l'instaurer dans notre pays il cible
particulièrement les 8 % de Français qui
consomment la moitié de l'alcool vendu
en France donc les très gros
consommateurs d'alcool et pas l'alcool
ordinaire et il cible également les tout
premiers prix d'alcool enfin il est pas
question ici de s'attaquer à quelconque
filière voire même la baisse de
l'asscise fait que les vignobles les
20ins produits dans notre pays ne
seraient pas impactés par cet amendement
donc c'est un amendement qui a trois
vertus ce prix minimum il permet à la
fois de préserver le secteur en
comparaison d'une augmentation de
taxation il permet également que les
taxes existantes demeurent assez
suffisantes pour financer le coût de
l'alcool et il permet effectivement
d'avoir une action puissante au niveau
sanitaire